one year into the trump presidency
hundreds of important executive branch
and other government positions remain
unfulfilled the administration nominated
559 officials in its first year that's
fewer than President Obama who nominated
658 officials by the same point and
George W Bush who nominated 741
president Trump's nominees are waiting
longer also for Senate confirmation
margot brennan is at the State
Department where many jobs are empty
Margaret good morning good morning well
those Senate delays have particularly
impacted the State Department and the
White House is partially to blame they
still haven't selected candidates for
top slots like representative to the
European Union or the ambassador's to
Turkey Qatar and South Korea I'm the
only one that matters because when it
comes to it that's what the policy is
going to be yet implementing the
president's decisions is the
responsibility of the government
officials who work for him one year into
the Trump administration hundreds of
those jobs are unfilled of the roughly
600 key executive branch positions just
241 have been filled
135 nominated candidates await
confirmation while 244 slots have no
nominee at all this president is lower
than any prior president has been in
getting their top people into government
max tire of the nonpartisan partnership
for public service the president and
bluntly the American people are missing
their top leaders in critical agencies
across the government there is currently
no IRS Commissioner National
Counterterrorism Center Director or
Census Bureau head White House
legislative affairs director mark short
I think it's part of Democrats agenda to
try to obstruct the legislative agenda
there's no US ambassador to South Korea
at a time when there is a crisis on the
Korean Peninsula
no nomination has been made why is that
I think that there's a couple places
where the administration needs to get
nominees forward to the Senate Margaret
I accept that but by and large the
challenge has been Democrats United
States obstructing their nominees here
at the Labor Department the deputy
secretary position or number-two spot
sits empty just like at the Department
of Commerce
education and while the administration
says it does want these critical
leadership positions filled they claim
that some of those spots that sit vacant
across the government are simply
unnecessary the president came to
washing tend to drain the swamp White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders if
we can have one person do a job instead
of six then we certainly want to do that
now secretary Tillerson has cut about 30
top envoy positions as part of his
restructuring effort but even he has
been frustrated by the White House
blocking some of his top staff choices
that coupled with Democratic opposition
has slowed down the Trump administration
about 40% of their nominees still await
confirmation Norah
it is incredible I'm glad we're doing
this story and even to think about -
there isn't an ambassador to South Korea
and this is one of the top time
challenges for the administration and
the Olympics and all of that so Margaret
thank you